this exclusive from the daily wire
it says a law firm that employed
virginia gubernatorial candidate terry
mcauliffe has made a cottage industry
out of aggressively fighting victims of
alleged sexual abuse in schools being
paid handsomely to defend school systems
that the girls say failed to protect
them
in one case
the hunton andrews kurth law firm where
mcauliffe served as a senior advisor
from 2019 until recently is battling a
young woman who says that and this is
horrific says that she was repeatedly
raped on her fairfax county middle
school campus
as a 12 year old and that she was
slashed with a knife
burned with a lighter and anally
penetrated
the law firm and mcauliffe's campaign
refused to comment on whether the law
firm still employs mcauliffe by the
deadline but mcauliffe reported income
apparently linked to the firm in 2021
after announcing his run for governor of
virginia on december 8 2020.
later advertisements from the firm for
mccullough fundraisers referred to
mcauliffe as a former colleague
um
the girl said she was afraid of having a
real name attached to the case because
one of her alleged tormentors had
threatened to kill her if she came
forward the mcauliffe-linked law firm is
seeking to have the case thrown out
because it was filed under a pseudonym
even though there's no dispute that the
school system knows who she is
um in a separate case and i can't read
this you got to go to daily wire read
the entire story but i'll read one more
example here it's a it's a long story an
important story
a girl alleged the fcps administrators
were told of an unwanted sexual incident
on a banned trip a school security
officer told her there was no point in
seeking criminal charges and that school
and the school gave an award to her
alleged abuser
hutton told the court that the school
system lost documentation showing his
investigation of the allegations in part
because it was not using a sexual
harassment allegation database that it
had promised to use pursuant to a
federal settlement in the other girl's
case
okay so if you're wondering
as i've been telling you about again you
can go to dailywire.com
and see the entire story there's another
exclusive story as we're doing
we're we're doing more uh
investigative pieces like this going out
and covering the stories that the
corporate media will not cover
these are this is real news real news
stories um and yet another reason why by
the way you should subscribe and become
a member and if you do that right now go
to dailywire.com subscribe and use promo
code real news uh you can become a
member of the daily wire
that way
but
if you're wondering the reason why this
story is so important
aside from the fact that terry mcauliffe
is trying to become the governor
of virginia
at a time when they have a crisis in the
school system with a lack of
accountability and and this is someone
wants to become the governor who's
partly responsible for that lack of
accountability but the other thing that
makes this so important is that
as i've been telling you about the the
epidemic of sexual abuse in the school
system
uh
one of the reasons why we don't we don't
hear about it
because of guys like terry mcauliffe
and the people in the law firm
and the tricks that the school system
plays
not just in loudoun county
um
but across the country
you know i told you about that ap report
this was
every once in a while you know the the
corporate media will do some real
investigation or report some real news
and so a few years ago the ap did a
report
about sexual abuse on public school
campuses
by students on other students and then
you've got you've got teacher on student
sexual abuse which is a whole other
category and there's thousands such
cases
and millions of literally millions of
victims of that but
the ap when they thought to look into it
a few years ago
they found that in that through the
previous few years there had been
something like 17 000 cases
17 000
just in that few year window and just
student on student abuse
this stuff is very common
very common
but we don't find out about it and uh
this is one of the reasons
all the different ways of
hiding it from the public
it's all about how they categorize these
incidents whether they choose to pursue
it and and pursue legal action
um
and then you also have kids who like the
the girl in the story
are terrified to come forward
i mean think about
all these me too cases we heard about
and the question was well how did how
did uh
you know how did weinstein
manage to to do this
for decades
without anyone coming really coming
forward and saying anything about it
um all of these all these victims all
these women who fell victim to it
i mean why didn't they come forward and
say anything why did it go on for
decades
and the reason that we're given is that
well they were afraid to do it they felt
intimidated
they were worried about their hollywood
careers and so forth
well if that's the case for adults
what about 12 and 13 year old girls
in middle school in high school
who fall victim to this what and and um
they've got no one advocating for them
no one on their
side what hope do they have
so this is a major story this is a major
far-reaching story across the country
and uh here's the daily wire we're going
to continue to pursue that and let you
know about it meanwhile
terry mcauliffe doesn't care about the
students who are raped
in loudoun county schools or in any
other schools but the students
themselves certainly care and that's why
hundreds of students across loudoun
county
we have some footage here staged a
walkout yesterday um because of loudoun
county's cover-up of of rapes of
students multiple rapes of students in
the loudoun county school system so you
can see there and it wasn't just one
school there were multiple schools where
the kids walked out
you see it here
well once again if you go to corporate
media for your news coverage you
probably didn't know this happened
so i want you to compare here we've got
hundreds of of of high school students
walking out because of of the sexual
abuse
and rape of their fellow classmates in
school during school hours
so compare the media coverage of that
which was nil there was basically no
coverage
to the you know
the the few dozen weirdos
who walked out of netflix headquarters
because
dave chappelle told some jokes that made
their tummies hurt
corporate media three weeks of coverage
for that and and still ongoing
i mean at the actual walkout at netflix
there were far more news cameras than
there were people walking out
but these kids
there's there's some local coverage and
then you're hearing about it from
conservative media but that's it
because this is simply not a
conversation that um
the corporate media wants to have
okay what else do we have here uh we'll
stay on the school board issue for a
minute
as we know it's not just a problem in
loudoun county here's a minus minnesota
school board which has instated new
rules to uh stop those domestic
terrorist parents from reigning terror
at uh at the school board meetings
here's here's jody sapp she's a school
board member
and here she is explaining the new rules
listen
i just want to remind everyone this is a
business meeting of the school board
it is not a meeting that belongs to the
public
each speaker is asked to state his or
her name and address for the record
failure to do so will result in an
individual
this is this is a meeting of the this is
not a meeting for the public
she says this meeting does not belong to
the public
no no jody
i got news for you the entire public
school system
is supposed to belong to the public
it is all public concern
all of it
that's why we call it the public school
system
but this is how they feel about it this
this is as parents this is simply not
your business
and if you're going to intrude in our
business which is deciding what your
kids are going to be taught and how
they're treated
and whether they're um
and whether their sexual abuse will be
reported to police and all that if you
want to intrude in our business then
you've got to follow our rules we're
going to make it as hard for you as
possible
so here she is explaining the rules keep
keep playing not being allowed to speak
john can you give us your name and
address please uh my name is john
wicklund i live in mankato could i get
your address please john um i'd rather
not since
you guys don't have it
and i get so much uh property damage and
eggs and everything else
from
fun people and their friends
you need to give your address all right
i live on fifth street
excuse me i live on fifth street
this house number
[Music]
okay he gave his house thank you all
right
so are our kids safe
um
effective tonight the school board will
enforce the following guidelines
open forum participants are prohibited
from calling out or addressing any
individual school board
or school district staff member if this
occurs open forum will be closed and the
individual will not be allowed to
participate in future open forums
crowd noise or any sort of grand
standing during open forum including
applause
talking hollering or any outbursts will
result in open forum being closed
further beginning at the november first
school board meeting open forum
participation will be limited to those
individuals who wish to speak to an item
on the board agenda the board agenda is
always made available the thursday prior
to
our meetings and they're always on the
district website this this
evil
wench
they all look exactly the same by the
way
all of the little mini petty
bulbous tyrants that are running our
schools they all look exactly the same
they're they're like there's there's
like a uniform for these people
and they all
they are so mad
that that parents are there
taking an interest in what they're doing
and trying to exert some actual
influence over the school system
and speaking up for their own kids they
are so angry about it
and that's why this
the response here has to be show up
show up get louder at the school board
meetings
keep showing up
more and more people keep doing exactly
what they don't want you to do
and don't stop
that's my one fear about um this school
board you know movement right now
is that is that it will it will just
stop and fade away and go away
and we we have let's be honest we have a
history of that on the right uh not just
on the right but in our culture where uh
people generally have the memories of of
you know
field mice or something and they
a couple days later it's like it never
happened you move on to the next thing
always always chasing the next shiny
object
there are a lot of things for us to
focus on in this culture a lot of
battle's worth having but this one has
to continue
because if two months from now we're
looking back on this and saying hey
remember when everyone was showing up to
school board meetings that was nice
and that's what we're saying two months
from now that none of this will will
matter
um we have to be relentless and
consistent
and that's been one of our big downfalls
i think of the conservative movement
is a lack of consistency
and not being being nearly relentless
enough
so keep coming keep getting keep
get louder and louder
the this is the lengths they'll go to
though
they what jody there is saying is you
have to say your address
into the microphone
like the guy pointed out when he was
sitting there well you already know the
address you know the address there's no
reason why i have to say it
the only reason why the school board
would insist that you say it is to
intimidate you
that's the only reason they are trying
to get people hurt
and they they are they are indirectly
encouraging mobs to show up to these
people's houses that's what they're
doing
there's no other reason why you should
have to say it
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated